Hello,
freak bitches.
What's the turtle thing?
What's,
that's a,
a jocular expression I guess from a Stephen Hawking book.
Um,
it's,
it's a,
it's like an old comedic reference to the infinite regress problem in cosmology,
which,
you know,
the
based on all the shit we were talking about earlier and there's a story,
I guess there was some professor at Oxford or somewhere were given a speech and
explaining how the universe works and,
and everything else in some little lady stood up and said,
you know,
it's really clever.
I know you think you're smart but you're wrong.
And he's like,
oh yeah,
well what's,
what's the,
what's the truth?
And she's like,
well,
the earth sits on the back of this giant cosmic turtle and carries it through
space.
And he said,
well,
what's carrying the turtle?
And she's like,
oh,
that's very clever,
but it's another turtle.
And he's like,
well,
what's under that?
She's like,
you might as well you're wasting your time.
It's turtles all the way down.
And so hocking referenced this in brief history of time.
And it's weird because you can look back,
I'm Hindu cosmology and a lot of,
uh,
some native American tribes,
they all held these earthly turtles and high reverence and the symbology of it
all and they find that story in different cultures throughout,
you know,
space but thousands of years.
But there's this weird weird referenced to this cosmic turtle and the Indians or
the Hindu thought there were these four elephant standing on the back of the
turtle and the earth was a flat disk rest on its back and it just cruised
through space.
There's a lot of artwork you can find associated to this.
And I just thought that it was really the law,
the record at its core is about love.
You know,
being like this one universal truth and you get a lot of people look to
religion.
A lot of people look to drugs.
I'm not saying you can't get really spiritual experiences from all those things,
but I think love at the end of the day is the one thing that really I've ever
found forced me to want to wake up and really try to be a better human being.
Every day,
you know,
so that was the main point of the album and the turtles thing was just kind of,
it's,
it's a way of saying if you get into an argument with somebody and you realize
it's just pointless,
you're going back and forth.
It's turtles all the way down because nobody really knows shit,
you know,
and we're all just trying to not kill each other.
So I don't know.
I decided it would make a good country song.
Maybe you just need to talk to Kirk Cameron.
You know,
you're talking a lot of shit,
but you don't really know until you sit down with Kirk Cameron.
Have you ever seen his buddy that shows that banana is proof of evolution?
That was the ray comfort.
Yes.
This dumb fuck.
Who doesn't even understand that we changed the way bananas look like this guy.
He caused the banana and the atheist nightmare.
Have you seen that video?
It's beautiful,
man.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
That video's beautiful.
Yeah,
it's and him and Duane Gish and the gish gallop where you're just like throwing
a word salad at somebody.
It's like,
oh,
well,
evolution isn't true because it's like,
dude,
shut up.
They're all just gay.
That's what it is.
That's fine.
No,
it's great.
Nothing wrong with being gay,
but I really believe that that's what's going on with most of those guys.
They're the reason why they're so hog.
Wild for Jesus.
Like Kirk Cameron.
That's a gay man.
I'm not a gay man,
but I'm pretty good at spotting some things in this life.
I know what a gay man it looks like.
I know know it all.
Gay Men look like I've been fooled before,
but you know what I'm saying?
It's like you put a fucking lizard outfit on dog.
I'm going to go,
hmm.
Something's up with that lizard.
What is this?
That same with the banana.
Oh yeah,
that's.
There it is.
Yeah.
Peeling it and.
Oh Wow.
Man.
Goof bag.
He doesn't eat,
but he never even bothered doing the work to understand that.
We used to have different looking fucking bananas within the,
within the written human record like that ain't that long ago.
Stupid.
Yeah,
it's and,
and somebody brought,
I think once somebody brought him an actual,
a non,
like an original natural banana and he was like,
what's that?
It's a banana.
You dumb.
Fuck,
sorry.
Because he started,
he knew that part of his brain is all just for fighting off cock,
fighting off the love of the COC.
So he puts that just,
I don't have any room for that.
I can't do that kind of research and busy fighting off the gay.
So I'll just sit here with this banana.
It's pontificate.
I mean he could,
if that,
if as any way shape or form a hypothesis were true,
it's my thesis.
Why?
Why are you such a phallic symbol?
Why did he,
for all the same reasons,
he doesn't understand what he's doing,
what's drawn to it,
the transference,
you know,
in,
into the symbol.
So it's actually giving them power.
It makes them feel comfortable,
but it's such a ridiculous proposition that God made a food that we could hold
perfectly well.
What?
Tomatoes are no good,
like why,
why can't you.
I mean a fucking tomatoes pretty easily held to like,
that's really stupid.
Why isn't banana shaped which tomato?
That's true,
right?
Yeah.
You've got cherry tomatoes carries,
hothouse.
Great.
You know,
all these different ones because we've modified them and we modified them.
We got involved.
Your light is.
Do you find it really rewarding to be out in this incredibly wild environment?
Like when you come to a city like you go from that to New York City.
Is New York City just like a cool little vacation for you and then do you do,
do you appreciate the wild or do you appreciate New York because of the wild or
both?
Does that make sense?
You know,
my lifestyle,
the challenges I face and overcoming that,
um,
there is such pride in yourself that,
oh my gosh,
I did that.
How cool is that
in being really little.
I mean,
I,
I terrified of the dark,
but now I live in a place that's dark for nine months out of the year.
You know,
I mean there are always challenges.
Know yourself better yourself,
you know?
Um,
when I go to a city
a bear,
I know exactly what he wants from me,
you know,
pretty much he's either going to eat you or he wants something here I was just
passing through,
but it's a pretty honest relationship.
He wants to eat me.
I don't want them to.
You go to a big city and I'm used to seeing my horizon.
I'm always checking things.
There's no trees,
there's no buildings.
There's nothing tomorrow.
My horizon,
I go to New York and you can't go eight feet and you've got a 60 story building.
How the hell do you check your horizon?
How do you know what's coming at you?
You see people,
but you cannot be guaranteed.
When I see a bear and he's charging,
I know he wants to attack me.
You see a person walking down the street,
you don't know whether he's going to pull a gun out of his pocket.
Shake your hand,
pinch your ass or wave goodbye.
You don't know.
So that's a Predator that I'm pretty impressed people want to be around.
When I got here,
look at all these lights and all these people.
I'm like,
oh my God,
and they're here on purpose.
What's weird?
And so I always wrestling with this whole time because when I go to these
places,
I love the culture.
I love the people.
Um,
even there I was trying to learn Swahili with some of the,
um,
the trackers that we're working with me.
Uh,
Rashidi awesome guy speaks only swahili but so I really invest myself into the
culture and I just want to learn.
I want to sort of get,
I want to see things through their eyes.
Well,
I saw these grass shacks and all these people in,
you know,
every grass shack had six little kids running around it.
And it was just like,
I'm thinking this is awful.
I mean,
it's no hope for six kids at every grass shack that seems.
I don't know,
it just seemed very sad to me,
but we're,
we're there getting ready to cross this river in the truck and the river was
high.
So we're kind of out a Ryan Shalom is the,
he's,
he owns Greenleaf,
Tanzania.
And so we're,
we're there and we're kind of seeing what's going on.
And there was a village about a quarter mile away and uh,
as we're looking at the river and trying to make a game plan,
there was music and just people singing and I'm like,
is it happy hour over here?
What is going on?
And it just,
that really just hit home.
It's like,
you know,
I see him and I think there's no hope and they must be miserable.
But they're laughing and singing and dancing
maybe.
Maybe they're okay.
I don't know.
I mean,
are they happy?
They seemed happy to me so I don't really care.
So it's weird.
It's,
you know,
I don't know.
I can,
I can look at it from outside and judge and say,
Oh,
you must be so depressed.
Maybe they're not.
I don't know.